i mean recently of course i've been
playing london but that's
because like i saw i remember i saw your
video on
on london specifically and then i just
started to
to watch more of your content but that's
basically the one that i know it's
london and
yeah basically when i that's but that's
when i started to learn chess is when i
go to sleep i always put a youtube video
to fall asleep
and it's usually one of like the last
one was your
10 hours tournament only chess or
wow no this uh yeah i think it was like
almost a 12-hour video
i can check the analytics and only i
think only like five percent of
viewers complete the whole thing yeah i
mean it took me two weeks but
but i've completed the whole thing wow
you know i get comments all the time
like people will
fall asleep watching uh i guess watching
my uh my content
so it seems like you are familiar kind
of
of the basics of the london um
based on what i saw in your at least
your recent games
and what i can do is invite you to uh
i'll each us study
and then we can kind of both see the
same board and we can kind of address
maybe address some of your recent games
address any questions you have
play some stuff out um yeah i know you
you mentioned okay london and then
you're also playing
some kind of like kings indian i saw
some sicilian games
i mean sicilian is so sicilian was the
first thing that i started playing in
black but then i realized that
i have to know so much theory that i
rather just play something that
is i can always play like that and
even though i know that um
usually kings indian should in theory
only be good against
king's pawn opening i i still just play
it against queens as well
i just i just start with the pawn
instead of the horse
just to have something more standard
that i'm
more used to sure yeah and that's
completely fine like at your level like
most of your games will not be
determined in the opening
and i saw like you're playing i think
you said you okay you start with the
pawn which uh
i usually it's d6 and then then you do
some setup like
like this um and
when it comes to the the names of the
openings um
this is actually called the pierce
defense
but it's like it's very very similar to
king's indian but pierce is against e4
and then king's indian is against d4
um okay now i think that that's like a
completely fine repertoire because
you'll you'll get a lot of positions
as black where you're kind of used to
employing this um
this fiance on the the king side
and um
yeah i saw a few of your games where you
do this um
without any issue and and then you you
get some
some very solid uh solid position from
the opening
and then that's nice because you save
time early on and then you can spend
more time
in like the later like more complicated
positions
yeah in the later com complicated
positions
i i feel like a lot of times i know i
know what's best but i
i feel so unsure because it's usually
like i can't really
i think i don't have enough games or the
games that i had i didn't play
pay enough attention to kind of get a
a photographic memory of if i did this
before or not
so i actually lose a lot of time just
rethinking if that's the right move or
not
yeah and i noticed you play a lot of
like just a lot of blitz chess
um which is maybe like the uh it's like
the go-to thing if you don't have much
time
or if you don't want to devote so much
time to just a single game
um but my like my recommendation if you
really really want to improve
is to play longer games okay
um i'm gonna make like a little bit more
about longer games here
so if you check my rating on uh
10 minutes it's actually 1.8 k
because if you start with the question
mark right
yeah and that player played two games on
my account
with 10 minutes because he was trying to
teach me stuff
so if he's 2k then it went really high
so i kind of use that to flex on people
i think that's actually the main reason
why i don't play longer games
you just want to preserve the rating
yeah i mean yeah
because it's still provisional then
it'll fluctuate a lot more in your first
several games
um i mean maybe you could like if you
really wanted to you could make a
another account just for like slower
chess yes i think i'll do it actually um
because you'll you'll learn a lot more
from games where you actually have time
to like think through the position
to really consider multiple options
before you make every move
to check before every move if you're
blundering something
um and you mentioned like this kind of
this more organized competition coming
up
oh yeah probably gonna be around 10.
yeah if it's gonna be
slower chess and like that your usual
three-minute chess
then you'll probably want to get in the
habit of practicing some sort of games
um i noticed like a good number of your
games are determined
by usually two two things
either blunders or time trouble
yeah and there are a lot of games where
like you were you played really well you
got a winning position but then you just
lost on time
yeah and then there's other games where
like you just make a one move blunder
and everything kind of just collapses
i feel like when i make one blunder i i
just have to make a blunder after as
well
i feel that a lot of times i i lose a
piece
so i just blunder another piece because
i'm
in the moment tilted or something no
this is this is so common
um it's kind of this uh downward spiral
effect
where yeah like once you make one
mistake it's so much easier to make like
many more mistakes and then let your
whole whole position just slip away
so this is really important because like
at your level
uh one like even one bad mistake is is
usually not enough to actually lose a
game
so if you if you find yourself like
blundering a piece for no
no reason it's just a careless mistake
you really want to try and stay focused
stay in the zone and avoid
tilting and use whatever resource you
have in the position
so maybe we can check out a few of your
games
uh i can i can maybe cover like the key
moments
and i had the idea also like sometimes
when i do these these sort of lessons
um we could also eventually
play a game against a viewer and then
team up and kind of talk through uh
talk through strategy and ideas yeah
that sounds good actually
um so yeah maybe we can cover like two
or three of uh
of the the moments in in these games and
then uh then then team up against a
viewer
so i think this is a game you played
with in the last few days
i really really like the way you played
the opening so this was carlson move
i remember that like yeah that when they
attacked the bishop you put it
backwards yeah so it's very clear like
you were following my my advice
um yeah and like you're you're happy
when they take because then you you open
the each file and this
is exactly what happened um
it was a very solid position
and then this one this is actually a
doubt kind of that i had
because i think i think i remember
hearing i think it was actually you
saying that
uh obviously when you're playing london
you kind of wanted to have the
that spawn structure but when they put
the horse here before moving this pawn
right then like then i should just
transition more into a i can't delete
the arrow queen's gambit
you can just yeah into a queen's pecan
but so that was kind of my idea because
i i guess that
if they push the pawn before the the
horse then
i should always put it here right but i
don't remember when
or i don't i don't know necessarily why
so there's a couple
uh yeah a couple rules to
usually follow of course it always
depends on the position
but you're exactly right like if they
block their c pawn with the knight
this is a nice move because you can
exert more pressure
against d5 and black can't easily
reinforce it with c6 yeah so your usual
plan when you play c4 is to play knight
c3
and queen b3 there's another case where
you you use the same idea
if we just go back to move two if um
if black average develops the light
squared bishop early
and i saw a few games that you had with
um your opponent
playing this move early then you still
want to go
for the setup with c4 knight c3 queen b3
so this is kind of the two cases to
remember if they develop their bishop
early
to f5 or g4 or if they block their c
pawn
that's when you go for this plan
against bishop f5 it can be even more
effective
because b7 is not defended
and then you're exerting pressure not
only against d5 but also b7
i think that was also an idea on the
queen's gambit right
but it was usually either the queen
there or the queen here
i remember seeing some positions yeah so
like there's
there's going to be similarities when
when you do play c4 it's
it's much more like a queen's gambit
than a london
this is more more like a queen's gambit
with your bishop on f4
um and a lot of players will kind of
they'll sometimes crumble early because
they can't cope with the pressure
on on the queen side and on top of that
like
in addition to queen b3 knight c3 your
rook can also
eventually come to c1 and very often
if the pawns get traded then the the
file will open up for your rook
and your pieces just coordinate really
really nicely yeah
that's usually what you want to strive
for um regardless of the opening you
just want like nice piece harmony
where your your pieces kind of work
together in the position
you're not just using one piece but
you're using a bunch of your pieces
to try and maximize the pressure against
the opponent
and sometimes this takes experience
because every every opening every
different position
it requires for different um sort of
setups
but um like with the london you'll kind
of see these
these cases repeat over and over again
yeah
so if we go to your game um yeah i
really like what you did
um i'm not a huge fan of queen d3
i don't remember why i did it yeah like
and this is the case with blitz like you
you played this move in five seconds
um i mean maybe you were like you were
anticipating black castling and you
wanted to
go for this sort of attack oh i think so
i
i actually think so um the main drawback
with this move
is that it it interferes with your
bishop yeah and
more often your bishop is happiest on
the square
and then if i do want to go there i can
also just put the queen on on c2
after yeah the queen is better placed on
c2 or
b3 and you're actually you're not
entirely sure like where your queen
is going to be best placed here so it's
better to be flexible
and make a move that you know you want
to play
yeah so that makes sense yeah like
bishop d3 and knight f3
they're like the most flexible moves
because you know like these are the
clear
best squares for your your minor pieces
and then i'll show you i'll show you
actually a bonus with bishop d3
because you're actually setting up a
trap in this position
which is pretty pretty characteristic
of this sort of um the situation when
you have the h file
imagine black castles here wait does it
doesn't that have a name i think i heard
about
isn't that the best sacrifice here but i
think it has a name i just
forgot about the name so there's
something called the greek gift which
maybe yeah
you're thinking of yeah exactly yeah
that was the name
um yeah this is very similar to a greek
gift
where you like you eventually sacrifice
and you have exactly the right uh the
right idea
um it's a bit different because usually
greek gift involves your night here
coming eventually to the square
but um but it still works here so you
you obviously considering this
but what's your follow-up imagine lack
takes
how do you uh how do you continue
wait do i sacrifice again no
yeah you have to be careful when
sacrificing too much because then you
might just run out of fuel yeah
you just i don't think that that would
work
or that you just lost i think that
now maybe i just put the queen on h5
yeah exactly and that's why that's one
of the benefits of leaving your queen
here
you now have this as an option and now
black's in big big trouble
yeah because he he can't even defend it
with the pawn i mean if he attacks my
queen it's useless
yeah g6 doesn't really solve anything
yeah i guess he can put the horse
back but then i just checked mate on on
the eighth rank instead of the seventh
so as far as i can see there's only two
moves for black that don't get
mated there's another try like rook rook
moving
somewhere yeah but this still gets mated
in two
you just take the knight and then
deliver me then i go down
yeah i mean it's so powerful when you
have the h file and box castled
um i guess he has to move the f pawn
yes and this is a case where like even
though black kind of
blundered allowing this to happen it's
not losing for black
if uh if that pawn is moved let's say f6
and then you still have to work to win
this but it's really nice for you
because you take the knight
and now i'll push his king to the center
or yeah
and actually what do i do here
as far as i can see you're not mating
because the king's always going to have
like an escape
yeah if you check black will just go
back
um so this is a case where
you probably want to bring in more
more attacks you can also look for
things which you're already attacking
like you can win a pawn here just look
at the big picture
yeah if i if i take the d pawn yeah just
take twice on d5
is nice and now you're keeping your
attack
actually this is something there's
something that happens me
a lot in the games which is whenever i
reach to a similar position like this
uh not exactly this one but just a
similar one i
just when i don't know what to do i just
keep checking and hope i get the
checkmate because i can't really see the
checkmate so i just
a lot of times i feel like i'm just
checking to check
and just hope that at some point it's
made gotcha yeah and this is another
reason
why it can be uh more beneficial to play
slower games
where you can actually like take your
time try and think ahead
and then consider your options because
this is a case where checking doesn't
really
it even hurts me yeah i mean
like i don't think it hurts you too much
but it doesn't
like accomplish what you're trying to do
um so
yeah and usually like when you're
attacking you you wanna you don't wanna
just play the first move that comes to
mind you wanna consider a few options
if you see a good looking move or if you
see a check consider other possibilities
and once you see this i mean this is
clearly very nice you bring the knight
in and then
the king is very much suffering and the
queen's attacked
and eventually you'll probably want to
bring your knight in and
just keep control on on the position
um okay so that was
um like up until this point i think you
you played like a grand master
like the first seven moves like they're
all moves that i i would probably play
myself
but queen d3 was like the first kind of
questionable
decision but not not a huge mistake it's
not a blunder it's just a small
inaccuracy uh and then
okay then the game continued and then
you went like hyper aggressive
um it's interesting like of course um
like when the king is castled on the
side you you do want to attack
uh when you play this move it looks
aggressive i don't really
see what you're threatening
because yeah this pawn's defended um
so it may have been better for you to
to just try and improve something else
in the position
um probably even i guess the bishop
or even the other knight doesn't seem
bad on
the square yeah actually knight e5
is is one option because if if black
takes
uh you're happy to get a pawn here and
this is very typical in london
to to bring your knight here um
and there's there's a few possibilities
i would consider a move like c5
where you're you're clamping down you're
opening this diagonal
eventually you might want to prepare
this the storm
of b4 b5
and then bring your rook in and when you
have pawns like this especially when
you're game
when you have more space on the side
your opponent is castled
it's a sure sign that you're going to
have good attacking possibilities
and you don't need to rush with just
like throwing pieces but you can kind of
slowly build up
and black it's going to be hard for
black to kind of play this position
and i'm guessing i guess i'm also
messing with this queen
because now she can too much because i'm
blocking the only diagonal that she had
open
yeah i know black is very uh cramped
here
like it's with so many pieces it's it's
claustrophobic for black
like the the pieces are just in the way
of each other and um
yeah not easy to uh to be active
um but okay knight b5 it still made
things interesting
and then you you still went for like
this pawn storm
uh and then okay then your opponent kind
of
counter attacked went from knight b4
you brought your queen back i i probably
would have preferred queen b3 just a
slightly more
uh useful square for the queen queen d2
maybe second best and
then you got you got a really nice
position this was definitely
uh almost definitely the best move
and i don't think you you realized it
but when you played this move not only
are you improving your knight but you're
setting up
a room i'm setting a fork
in almost a fork yeah i mean my idea was
a fork but then i oh wait the
horse is defending but then i didn't
went for it
so what ended up happening was black
yeah black attacked your queen and in
this position
you have a really nice oh wait maybe you
don't
oh never mind oh so okay
i have to explain what's going through
my mind here because i i was about to
say when you play this move
you're threatening to take the knight
and then
fork the king rook and queen
oh but let me ask you why why is this a
bad move why
why does this not work i mean it looks
really good
because you're gonna fork but i think
it's because so so if i
so if i take right yeah
what happens
huh
how can black punish you in this
position
wait what he can't check me with i i
don't see it
he can't check me with the horse so so
it's actually it's it's very simple he
can't check you
no he can't check you with the the um
the horse but
he can he can check you with something
else
oh he checks me with the queen yeah so
you don't even have time to afford it
yeah
so no i looked at this earlier and i
only now like i'm just realizing this
would be terrible for you
so it's what we call tunnel vision where
like you're so focused on your own idea
of like a forking
you don't realize the big picture and
the fact that your king could be a
target
so um again this is why
it's helpful to have more time to
actually think through these yeah these
possibilities
because my idea i think
sorry my first thought in the game would
be how can i remove this horse to
fork right away right because if this
fork is
if this horse is out then here also
forks the queen and the
and the king i think sure is what i i
would be thinking
yeah and you you played the best move
here you played um
queen d1 um
because you don't really have any
tactics giving your queens attacked
and uh your opponent
f6 and then
somehow things just collapsed for you
really really quickly
it was unfortunate because your position
still looks good
but you have to be careful not to
underestimate black's attack
yeah i think that i think that here i
should probably
shouldn't i play queen to
queen e4 a4 yeah yeah so queen a4
is definitely a consideration and it
looks nice because you're you're
counter-attacking
i don't know if it's effective though
because if
black takes your knight you do take and
you get in one check oh but the key is
going to escape
that's true and now these nights are
going to be kind of monsters
so i think you did what you had to do
and then in this position
you made the same mistake as you made
a long time ago on move eight
when you played queen d3 should take
with bishop you should take with bishop
your bishop's just happier here
yeah and then it gives your king a
better uh kind of safe square
then the game would continue but you're
not you're not running into too much
trouble
what happened in the game it was very
unfortunate because this still looks
okay
but queen before and then you don't
really have a good way to get out of
check
because you can't yeah every time that i
block the horse sticks
yeah and you if you move to d1 you get
forked
yeah so you move to e2 and then this is
also just
really unfortunate because i can't block
again
yeah i so i i would not have resigned
here i would have played it out
just because there's a really funny like
checkmate black and deliver
um what could happen let's imagine you
play king f3
obviously black could take the rook and
you're you're just pretty much hopeless
but
uh better for black to take the pawn
and then your king kind of goes for a
walk
and then takes and then here and then i
mean there's some funny lines where like
your king goes into
black's territory
and then i would imagine maid is
somewhere like
might take uh some some additional moves
if we go back maybe
queen g5 is a simpler way to end the
game
yeah man in this screen is always so
well coordinated with the horse
i can't do anything yeah yeah and this
is kind of
the brutal thing about chess like you
you played well to kind of build up your
position
but kind of miss black's
counter play yeah and uh
yeah like i guess it it
was just a matter of some small mistakes
not realizing the danger
like this i this was your final mistake
taking with the queen
yeah um but i'm still proud like i'm
still very proud of the opening like you
got exactly what you
uh you want out of this
um so yeah it goes to show that like the
the majority of games are determined
like much later on beyond the opening
in like these kind of messy situations
so if you want to look at uh maybe one
more game
from the black side
i did bring in a few games that you won
actually some of the games you won you
just played really
like principal chess um
oh so this one so this one was yesterday
i remember this game
i still remember this game and i know
like a lot it seems like
um at least some of the players you run
into like they'll try and beat you
quickly with this like
uh scholarships um which shouldn't work
and the way you punish them it doesn't
work anymore yeah
yeah so the way you punish them is but
just by focusing on developing your
minor pieces
if they're bringing their queen out
early you can usually use your minor
pieces
to chase around the queen because you
have a clear target
just be careful like if they play this
um want to defend f7
yeah usually with e6 even 95.
um i like what you did like you were
very efficient with development
um and this was yeah that was
almost a model game but i wanted i
missed making one
i remember i watched this game i missed
between one here
it's not something you would normally
expect to have so early
but uh i think i actually pre-moved for
the queen to take the pawn oh
yeah you were again maybe tunnel vision
you were fixated on on winning a pawn
but
yeah that's unfortunate i have i have
mate in one yeah
actually i think like because in this
case i just
this was after we we talked on twitter
and i'm like okay i'm just gonna
try to play something else than king's
indian
but the hard time that i'm having on
kings india now is
when to push the e pawn and when to push
the c pawn oh
yeah and sometimes it's um it depends on
what light does
so i um i can give you a recommendation
that would maybe simplify your life
at least against e4 if if they play d4
you kind of you usually stick with the
setup yeah and i would usually recommend
pushing the e pawn
um if they play e4
you could play sicilian and i know you
you had
mentioned earlier that like there's a
lot of theory in sicilian and you don't
want to be overwhelmed with so much
um but you could play a variation of the
sicilian called the dragon
which is basically still a king's indian
setup
it involves d6 yeah it involves
basically all the moves you play in the
king's indian
but you just include c5
and that usually discourages white from
getting like full control over the
center
too early yeah i think i was also eluded
because when when a lot of times that
this happens
uh i feel like so basic that's why
i i usually i think i think i just got
like a bad impression because
a lot of times i get i was getting this
position
and this is just at my understanding at
least this was always bad for white
because
this would wait it wasn't no it wasn't
this wait it wasn't with this
maybe d4 yeah and this was always
terrible for for them when i would do
this
yeah it's not a good one yeah so
i think i think i got tunneled where i
got so many games in the beginning like
that
that i was like yeah i mean it's
actually fine most of them will just
fall into that but i mean but it does
make sense so what i do is just
when they open with this i open uh i
don't want to play
i guess this yeah white can do a variety
of things
right um but yeah you usually stick with
your the same setup you play d6 because
you want to play knight f6
and you don't want them you don't want
to deal with this move
um so if i mean white can develop in
um like naturally maybe this move
uh you play knife six uh
and there's a few like kind of general
rules to keep in mind
if white ever plays d4
you just instantly take okay instantly
take you don't you don't want to leave
the tension you don't want to give the
white option to pushing forward
so you take and then you just you focus
purely on completing your kingside
development
and the nice thing about this over
like the pierce defense which is what
you were normally playing
is white doesn't have the two center
pawns
and you've opened this file which could
be useful later like when you complete
development your rook can come to see it
and there's there's ideas at this point
should i be worried
of bishop b5
um usually not it's it's a check
but uh it's not like a a lethal check
you just
you just block and you don't mind the
trade
i because i saw a lot of times that like
i saw
a lot of times when i was trying to
understand sicilian that i would see a
lot of people either pushing this pawn
or this pawn when this diagonals were
open
and i i never really understood that
much why but i
as of a lot of things that i've saw in
those videos
i just did it anyway gotcha yeah yeah
there's cases
where pushing the pawns could be useful
but
i mean very often if it's not like a a
super strong threat
and you'll have ways to defend against
it there's no need to
yeah to waste your time pushing upon
and slowings like slowing down your
development
your your main focus should be
developing as quickly as possible
and being efficient with like mo try and
move
every minor piece just once and
um and usually white will do the same
thing
um like the common setup for white is
bishop e3
you play bishop g7 and then white has a
bunch of moves here
if white plays something a bit timid
like bishop e2 you castle
you then develop your knight and
you get some kind of nice harmony you
kind of get a set up where
everything's defended your pieces are
not too much in the way of each other
um and you you have some nagging
pressure against this pawn too
uh and very often you'll complete
development like bishop d7 rook c8
maybe later you'll like one middle game
plan is to play a6 and then b5
yeah and then just go for support also
try to kick out that knight and then the
bishop can attack the pawn
so yeah if you got a pawn to b5 you can
then like try and remove this knight
from defending the
the e4 pawn
um so it's funny uh about
uh maybe a couple months ago i gave a
chess lesson
to david pakman he was participating in
this uh this pog chest
pog champs tournament yeah from
chess.com and we had a whole lesson
on the sicilian dragon and king's indian
so it's one of the openings i like i
highly recommend
for uh for players in like the i guess
like the 1000 to like 1800 range because
it's simple to learn
it's reputable um
and it's hard to go wrong if you know
the basics
i mean yeah it makes it makes a lot of
sense i never
thought that i could play that against
uh
against the pawn push but at least now i
have three different things to do you
know
but at least all blacks are really
similar yeah right
and one thing like if you have this this
tournament coming up and you know who
you're playing
then maybe you can you can prepare
beforehand like what
like see what they play as white and
then then choose
something where you would be most in
your comfort zone yeah
no i mean that's that's actually good
so you wanna uh i mean we could like
keep analyzing
some of your games or openings but you
want to like play a
team up and yeah let's do it let's team
up that sounds good
so i'll let you play
so you think so you want us to lose
i want i want us to learn or i want you
to learn holy
so i mean i think it will be fun
yeah um and no pressure i i'd recommend
uh trying to find an unrated like casual
challenge
and you might start to get challenges oh
i see let me see if
um
this is friendly but it's in portuguese
you know
okay so actually i want someone higher
rated than me
so i'll just take this oh yeah leo uh
yeah leo is uh
mine okay it's friendly do you bet you
see this like look at this
oh you're reading yeah let me um let me
follow you
um
oh this is awesome so we're kind of
getting
exactly what we just looked at yes
no so like knight c6 is okay that's a
move you usually play
yeah but i do recommend playing d6 first
but um should i still go for
that thing because i know i shouldn't i
shouldn't take
i should let him take right
um yeah so whenever the knights are kind
of staring at each other
you just leave your knights on c6 you're
always happy to take with your b-pawn
if they do take yeah so it's not a big
concern
i guess i'll try to go for the second
that's great yeah
and you're actually playing what's
called the the accelerated dragon
this is um oh how's it cuz i don't play
with
it's accelerated because i don't play
this pawn right because you didn't play
your pawn
or knight first you're going straight
for um
for the thing for the theme exactly
and this is an opening i've i enjoy
playing myself even at like the highest
levels
um it's fun because you get this bishop
uh they call it the dragon because
the bishop um kind of breathes fire
along the long diagonal it puts a lot of
pressure
against uh against the d4 square
but there's a bunch of different targets
awesome but not actually like before
playing the knight i guess i should
actually play the pawn
so yeah playing the pawn first is fine
um
actually both moves are playable so by
playing the pawn
it kind of it goes back to what we're uh
yeah well
i was hoping he would have taken the
night so then i think yeah well you're
still happy if you ever take some night
you're very happy to take back with pawn
um
okay so far so good and
so our opponent is playing uh like a
very well known setup
um and we're going into uh
into like pretty well-known territory
but you you just want to keep
developing kind of as i showed you
um so in this case
yeah that's the best square for the
bishop and the the whole point
because the bishop uh at least on d7 it
doesn't come to life so quickly but you
you really want to free the square for
the rook to come to see you yeah
all right now here i know i should not
take
so you do have to be careful
um i want you to notice one thing though
when
white played bishop h6
what's defending it oh [ __ ] oh that
sucks
i was gonna say that the um look at this
later but the queen was uh
was defending both the knight and the
bishop simultaneously oh
yeah so if i take the knight now then i
can take the bishop so you could have
taken the knight that
like it was a bit complicated but um
taken and if he takes
then i'll just you could
there are some complications we can we
can address later
um so life goes on don't want to get too
tilted
um
i know i deliver the consequences
i think this is not bad
so in a position like this because white
castle queenside
the the main strategy is to try and
attack on the queen side
um and
it's a bit tricky here because
yeah your uh your d-pawn is a bit weak
but uh
yeah you can go you could go for an
early b5
you do have to be careful of what white
is doing too
and uh because if actually white's
playing this very well
you have to be very very careful of this
this h-pawn moving forward
um i think for now you're still okay
like
you can go with your your initial plan
like you want to play b5
i think
but you can also i was thinking if
blocking here with the horse would do
any good
uh oh knight h5 yeah that would actually
probably be a mistake because white
would play g4
and then you're just losing time like
you'd have to move again yeah
that's true so i like b5 because
you want to generate uh what we call
initiative like you want to start making
threats
on the queen side but yeah okay here you
have to take
it's going to turn into like a very
sharp position i actually really like
that move
um because you're preventing white from
playing h5 himself now this is a very
important decision
what to take back with i think i have to
take back with the knight
exactly yeah and you keep you can keep
white's rook out and then maybe at some
point putting my rook there
so what does he want to do with this bad
boy fork me here but he can't
queen tanks
yeah he doesn't really have a threat i
mean this is still a good move like he's
improving his knights but
you do have options here
and for you it's about like trying to
improve some of your pieces which aren't
doing
the night here is not bad but i don't
know if it's good for me to trade it
that's the thing no because i lose a
pawn actually
yeah there's no reason to actually move
your knight here i
recommend either improving your rook on
the queen side
to get to the c file or or bring your
bishop to
a more active so a better square but
rookie is nice
i mean i was thinking here just because
it's kind of
open yeah c file is nice because like
the king is on the c
file and um that's half open for you
i like that yeah because now you pin the
knight your bishop comes to life
yeah and with this move you're actually
threatening
um you're threatening a really really
nice move here
this year no i mean at least that's what
i'm thinking
um yeah you're i'm looking at your
stream it was slightly delayed but yeah
you were right with bring your knight in
now it's but now it's tricky because
like he's offering a trade
be careful of your rook on c8 aligned
with his bishop
yeah extracted the safety against me
i don't this this is this doesn't seem
good
but doesn't seem bad so that was a
really risky move
because you you okay you you did win a
pawn but now you're putting your
your queen in the face of danger
yeah um and you might get punished for
it
but if you maybe he won't see it
i think you're still like it's still
tricky for white to punish you
you know the downside is the files are
open
um i definitely benefited white to
have that pawn removed
oh here we go
time things i mean the thing is now if
you can
just if you can trade queens
and hold on to your pawn you you might
even be better in the end game
um but the question is how
how you're gonna weather the storm of
white's attack
and now you have to be careful because
your queen is actually tied down to
defending your knight
yeah if you move backwards
then then you lose your knight so
there's only there's only one move it's
a forwards move
to keep your knight defended and
not not not blocking if you block on g3
then you lose a knight because there's
two attackers
so you have to move your queen
i'll tell you queen f3 is the best move
here
queen f3 it's i i think it's the only
move that doesn't give white
oh wait never mind my pawn is still i
yeah i forgot my pawn was also it's
still defending the night oh that i mean
it's
not because it's spinned oh wait
wait maybe there's some confusion with
notation there
oh yeah wait you said queen queen what
queen f3
f3 which is uh i'll show you after the
game
oh yeah i know we we don't see each
other's arrows
okay so we just lost a knight no
but uh this is where we don't want to
get like we don't want to collapse
i want to try and keep fighting um
well at least you you are making a
threat you're actually making two
threats here you're threatening knight
f3 yeah with a fork you're also
threatening the c2 pawn
unfortunately she will just stick twice
yeah
you you have to take back i mean yeah
yeah
and then oh
okay this actually gives you oh maybe
this just
destroys you that was a really good move
actually
uh i don't know i have 17 seconds yeah
just have to pray
yes gonna be a tragic finish
yeah here wow
yeah okay so there's a lot to take away
from that game
and this is sometimes what will happen
when you play like kind of a new opening
um you you'll you'll run into a lot of
kind of
new situations uh so i can do
we share it again on case study right
yes i have to find our study first
um just bear with me one moment
just have to add the game
here we go okay
okay yeah let's take a look um
okay yeah opening was very fine
um now this is one of the main like
attacking plans like against better
players
this is something you you could easily
run into
um basically exactly what our opponent
went for
this early bishop h6
so in this position i think you you may
be played a bit uh too impulsively like
e5
i know this is a move that you usually
play in king's indian
it's not a good move in the dragon for a
couple reasons
um blocks the bishop it blocks a bishop
and it makes your pawn on d6 very weak
oh yeah so e5 is almost never good
um now in this specific position i
should just take the knife you could
have taken the knight yeah
and um what's going on here this is what
we call an overworked piece the queen is
basically doing too many jobs at once
and taking the knight exploits that
but if it takes my so you should take my
bishop now no not so this is a more
complicated variation if he dicks your
bishop
what would you do here
uh
because it's a bit weird like for the
time being it's equal material i think
i think i will take his f pawn
with the horse yeah you take the pawn
because you know your knights
if you take his bishop you lose your
knight yeah you only get the most value
for your knight you take the pawn
and now he can't actually he doesn't
have time to lose
the queen exactly so if he takes your
knight
then you take the bishop and i'm one
pawn ahead and you you won yeah you
basically won a pawn
after all said and done so
uh so this move was a mistake yeah
um usually what white should do here
like the main move i think is bishop um
this is like one of the main lines
i think in that that was happening as
well i mean
actually this is kind of king's indian
every time that i play against this
setup with the queen and the
and the bishop in the same diagonal and
i see a bishop there i get really
stressed
oh it seems like so strong i just get
stressed
yeah so this is i guess one of the
benefits when you play the dragon
uh white house be careful playing this
too early because you have pressure
against d4
on top of that very often you just allow
this and you you can you can focus
on your attack on the queen side
yeah um like at some point sometimes
queen a5 is
is a nice option and then later pushing
your b-pawn
um but just to give you a sense of one
of the main ideas
if bishop c4 here you would play rook c8
you put pressure
on the diagonal or on the on the file
again if white plays this it's a mistake
because now you take and
um now now in this case the bishop's
attacked yeah
so most people play bishop b3 and then
one nice idea here for for black
is to maneuver your knight to this
square on c4
and you can play knight e5 and try and
get in with your knight
and your rook would support it and then
later
go for these sort of ideas
when should i when should i feel
comfortable on starting a
pawn storm because i don't understand
really well the difference between
pawn storm and over extending my pawns
oh sure um so when
it's sometimes hard to generalize but
i'll say when there's
opposite side castling so when you're
castle kingside
and the opponent's castle queenside or
vice versa
that's usually a time where you should
try and transform as quickly as possible
or find other ways to use your pieces to
start making threats
on the side that your opponent's king is
on
and very often like you can you can try
and pawn storm
like a6 is sometimes a slow move so
sometimes you'll just play b5 and then
sacrifice a pawn
just to open a file and i should always
play that
if especially if i already have a pawn
here like in
some games oh there's other cases yeah
like in the more closed
sort of variation um where you can still
go for this expansion
and then then like you can have a pawn
chain where everything's supported
yeah um so yeah there is kind of this
concept of overextending
but if you have enough supporters
then usually it's okay to go into your
opponent's territory as long as there's
more defenders than your opponent has
attackers
so uh
what happened okay so if we go forward
in this game
yeah unfortunately like once you play e5
you're kind of stuck then it's
lost um so it's not lost and there are
chances later on
uh if we just go forward here okay so
you went for the spawn storm
i like this move yeah if white plays h5
it's actually really
yeah it's it's yeah and just one lesson
for our opponent what um
what white could do here is play h5
immediately
and um because if i take because if i
take
it it's also i'm also kind of doomed so
if you take
then white gets basically uh
of extremely powerful attack he just
pushes this pawn right g4 yeah every
every white move will now come with a
threat
so g4 attack your knights if you move
back then white can take
and you really never have time to
actually carry through with your own
attack yeah
and you're probably just getting mated
here after this move
um your knight's tied down to mate and
white's threatening to take your knights
yeah so that's a classic thing of how
things can just go terribly wrong for
black
i think that also looking for those
ideas it's also something that i need to
do with more
like uh trying to remove the defender
and things like that like that that
night here i don't know if i would
see it usually yeah yeah and sometimes
you just need more time to
to make the observations and then
consider the options yeah
um but it also comes down to pattern
recognition
uh like this is a pattern i see very
quickly because i've had very similar
positions so many times over the years
and
you build up this intuition by by
playing a lot of games and then
reviewing those games and looking for
missed opportunities
um so you are still alive here
and you might even like be a little bit
better
um kind of even
but yeah i saw this in the engine
already
engine says i should take oh yeah the
engine will maybe
give some some
yeah better recommendations so i like
this like when you play this move
you have the very nice idea of bring
your knight in
and even if the engine says white's
better
uh if white's not careful you you could
very quickly just
be winning material so i should still do
it and
don't care about the bishop
well okay what happened the game yeah
unfortunately you can't quite
get away with this i don't think um
it's interesting because if you leave
your bishop undefended
and hanging then you win the queen
wait what wait so slow motion replay
so you you um after bishop h3 you played
an id for ignoring your bishop
yeah and then you would win white's
queen
the problem is you're still worse
because white
even the white lost a queen white one so
much
into pieces yeah which
uh it's still like maybe it's still fun
to play with the queen like you have the
only queen on the board but
it is objectively bad for you all right
actually that
that didn't even cross my i didn't even
see that that possibility
so one so one thing to consider whenever
like you're attacked in chess because
like the the normal response to when
your opponent attacks you
is to look for how to defend but always
keep in mind the possibility of making a
counter attack
so you you want to look for defense as
like the first consideration but you
also want to look for counter attacks
because in some cases counter attacks
can be very very powerful
unfortunately not in this case yeah this
case it gets too much material
yeah yeah and um okay this was a brave
move
and maybe just like really bad but um
i maybe would work for for
way worse players but it's just bad
yeah like against a good enough player
they're going to punish you and
um because like going back to the
opposite side castling situation
you don't want the files to open on the
king's side
yeah so you like this pawn here actually
keeps you safe
because the rook has less scope so it's
even better
so i should just take the bishop so if
you take the bishop yeah then
um then the rook is just behind the pawn
you're blockading the pawn
and i guess i still have the idea of but
if i bring the horse i guess i just
so now now you would lose yeah you don't
have enough support unfortunately
um i mean maybe you would go for some
like trade like maybe you can just go
for a queen trade and then
the game will go on and at least you'll
you'll be surviving
yeah and if white's not careful maybe
you can snag this pawn
um so it's still playable
but yeah after this yeah that's that's
just really bad
yeah so um i i had i told you to play
queen f3 i think
maybe you you didn't realize no i i i i
yeah i didn't
see i mean i i think it's still losing
but this i think this is the best
try practically to keep your knight
defended
um i'm sure the engine will find like
the
the knockout blow engine just wants to
destroy you
but um yeah if white doesn't play f5 and
you you maybe get like
one extra move um
to maybe snag this pawn and bring your
knight in there's some hope to
to stay alive but it was a good game our
opponent played well like nothing yeah
it's good it's a good learning
experience actually
i i need i need to i need to take more
time
to actually review games more than
uh to simply just just play and then
definitely yeah because then you'll get
a lot more value
and like yeah um regardless of the
result if you
if you analyze if you especially if you
analyze the losses
then um
also help a lot definitely yeah
yeah so it takes some discipline i know
it's fun just to hop on play some games
try and win as much as possible but it's
a lot more right
but then the mindset is wrong to improve
you know because i've also like
when i was playing one minute games it
was also i'm just gonna play random
moves because everyone loses by time
right because like
no one thinks in my elo so then i would
get like some mulo just
just making random moves and but that's
just not the best way to learn so
yeah i think i think i'll go to 10
minutes especially
especially if the tournament's also
going to be like that
and and try to understand the dragon or
try to get a lot of games where i can
get
uh similar positions and then just be a
bit more used to
what is the the best play when i see
something similar
yeah yeah especially when you're like
practicing a new opening like experience
is key
so getting getting like game situations
where you can
uh further learn the ideas and uh
yeah i think uh i think hopefully
more similar to my game than
it seems with
like uh there are concepts that are
similar like tempo is a concept really
important in our game
the same thing like leader of legends
yeah yeah
so it's like it's actually it's actually
way similar than than what it seems
yeah no i was going to ask about the
overlaps like i'm sure like the concept
of like
losing like really learning from your
mistakes and your life
no the way to learn is is similar um
i think that the fact that it's a game
that it's
uh or a chess is also a game that is
uh conditioned by your previous actions
just like league because i don't know if
you know any other games but for example
counter strike
so i'm not too familiar with uh yeah
other than
so shooting games work by rounds which
means that
you just have a fresh opportunity after
x time
right but both in chess and league that
overlap
exists and then i think the most
interesting is
and and you kind of like made me realize
this in in this call
that a lot of times the best move
or there is a spectrum of best moves and
if the engine tells you that something
is the best move
that doesn't mean that something that
maybe will give you less
points of the engine um maybe that move
makes the opponent
more or it makes more risky for the
opponent to make a bigger mistake
yeah i know this is very common like
that the engine will like
it arrives at the best move in a much
different way that humans will arrive
so that's something like really similar
considering that
something that is still good for you but
maybe not the best
puts an opponent on a harder position to
make the best possible choice
right yeah and a lot of it comes down to
uh
like up like fine finding initiative
finding ways to attack the opponent
and um i mean the engine will sometimes
be more materialistic where
yeah consider both we'll see everything
um
like it'll go for a line where it
requires like 10 perfect moves to
to have an advantage but that's not
realistic for for years
so um yeah you have to sometimes take
the engine recommendation with a grain
of salt
and um
and yeah just um i mean i think if uh
if if you use the engines to maybe see
where you you made like the biggest
blunders that can still be useful
but it's not always good at recommending
like the
the best strategy in a given position
yeah
i mean to me at least this was like
really helpful